This trip has been fantastic so far. A little disappointed it’s raining, but the group
has been in high spirits nonetheless.
I’m mostly impressed with this group because so few of them have been backpacking before.
I think they are already outside
their comfort zone with people they don’t know very well.
And they are also doing something they don't know how
to do.
I think it's a very risky and impressive first move.
I love the outdoors and
I’ve always wanted to…
I grew up in China and never had the opportunity to go
hiking and camping
and I thought that
I really wanted to
be in the outdoors and go on a hiking trip like this. I was really excited about it.
I think it's the ultimate equalizer in that
everyone's out here with the same gear holding the same weight,
without a shower, without deodorant,
no one looks their best, but we are all having fun. We’re in close quarters bonding and
there's very little judgment out here.
As a senior,
I've really enjoyed talking
to the incoming freshman
and sharing my experiences
and
my thoughts on life at Harvard.
I think this is
a great group of freshmen
that are very understanding and mature,
that are
better than me when I was a freshman.
I came in as a freshman
very anxious about making friends
and going to what felt like a huge school, across the country from home
and my FOP trip was where I met people that I really connected with
and from there I believed that I could make friends
in college. It was my first support system and
it carried through
into the new friends I made at schoo.